je dois vous prévenir avant que vous
n'en triez dans le manoir ça pourrait
changer le cours de votre vie tout
entière de quelques photos
vous dites ça maintenant
[Musique]
ce manoir était étrange
c'est fantômes n'ont absolument pas
l'intention de s'en aller
route dans tous les coins de cette
maison
Seigneur fiches nous la paix il y a
tellement de gens ignobles dans le monde
c'est eux qui font hanté
moi j'aime bien les surprises c'est un
autre que moi voit ça j'espère que toi
aussi
on doit se battre que ça nous plais ou
non sinon on sera tous coincé ici pour
l'éternité
bon il va falloir qu'on pose des limites
ce manoir regorge dame perdu mais il y a
toujours de la place
pour une de plus
[Applaudissements]
autrefois
des gens
dîner ici
je vous l'avais dit qu'elle était douée
non c'est une salle à manger
[Musique]
on a mis a été agressé il était grand
avec des cheveux qui ne sortaient d'une
sorte de nous oui
il avait oui comme un haut de forme
ouais je m'attendais à ce qu'il en sorte
un lapin les yeux il était un peu
enfoncé
et il était souriant genre ouais comme
ça exactement il ressemblerait à ça
vous avez fait ça à l'instant là